bene
grazie di essere qua
allora mi chiamo giovanni lanfranchi e
mi sono sempre occupato di tecnologia e
in particolare della parte software
software sviluppo software quindi mi fa
estremamente piacere oggi e saremo a
condividere con voi come il software si
sta evolvendo e dove se vogliamo ci sta
portando devo confessare che pensando a
quello ai punti che volevo toccare oggi
inizialmente la tentazione della di
quella di stupirvi con effetti speciali
di parlare dei soliti tre quattro esempi
in cui uno diciamo accidenti però poi
alla fine si porta a casa probabilmente
poco della invece che quello che vorrei
fare proprio di darvi l'idea della
interazione del software in termini di
la trasformazione profonda che ha non
solo a livello tecnologico ma anche a
livello sociale e culturale
organizzativo e come tocca la vita di
tutti noi quindi pensando a questi
processi di trasformazione forti siamo
in un convegno di
raptim innovation exponential innovation
ma mi è venuto naturale pensare a come
il nostro mondo come il nostro universo
si è diciamo evoluto e è stato
sicuramente una un succedersi di
elementi di forte disruption di rottura
seguiti da inter inframezzati da
elementi di continua innovazione
continua evoluzione continua adattamento
quindi
partendo dal big bang partendo al
andando a quando 60 milioni di anni fa
di ester alcuni asteroidi hanno
completamente cambiato le speci
dominanti sul pianeta per arrivare a prà
diciamo evoluzione darwiniana che ha
portato al all'attuale mondo diciamo che
poi ci sono anche altri altre evoluzioni
di cui non avremo modo di parlare oggi
ma sicuramente diciamo questo è un
paradigma che personalmente penso sia
estremamente efficace lo diceva parola
un franchi però noi siamo qua per
parlare di software che c'entra
l'asteroide il
dinosauro me perché se cambiamo
ecosistema
passiamo dalla cosmologia a quello che è
l'evoluzione del compiuti a quella che è
l'evoluzione del software diciamo che le
meccaniche meccanismi le dinamiche sono
le stesse
anche qua abbiamo avuto diciamo dell
this raptim innovation dei momenti di
rottura
che si sono man mano succeduti e
inframezzati anche qua da un continuo
adattamento da continua evoluzione una
continua interazione e quindi ripeto non
vi voglio annoiare con la storia del
compiuti in 30 secondi ma abbiamo avuto
man mano delle varie specie dominanti
sul pianeta del software partner dai
mindframe a cui poi
sono state rimpiazzate da plastic client
server e dal personal computer e poi
siamo arrivati a un'altra specie
dominante che al browser quindi la rete
l'internet e perché vi dico questo
perché oggi ce ne stiamo probabilmente
non rendendo conto ma siamo all'interno
di un'altra disruptive innovation e non
è assolutamente chiaro dove questa ci
porterà ma è sicuramente un elemento
estremamente importante che sta e andrà
a cambiare la vita di tutti noi
quindi per continuare un po con queste
analogie
diciamo cosmologiche
quello che oggi sta succedendo e che ci
sono due sistemi quasi 2 2 falli che si
stanno fondendo da una parte o il mondo
it il mondo del software come siamo
abituati a considerarlo il mondo dei
database il mondo delle transazioni il
mondo dell'applicazione quindi un mondo
che si è evoluto negli ultimi 20 25 anni
dall'altra parte c'è un altro mondo il
mondo delle interazioni il mondo del
social il mondo del cloud e
ripeto questo porterà a una nuova
un nuovo continente a nuovo modo di
vedere il software di vedere il
computing e in cui ripeto la specie
dominante non è ancora chiara ma ciò che
è chiaro che ci sono quattro grosse
forze che stanno diciamo a interagendo e
agenti in questo senso la prima forza è
sicuramente la parte di mobility che non
è tanto il cellulare o loro o lo
smartphone ma è proprio il modo in cui
oggi smartphone è diventato quasi un
accessorio un'estensione un'appendice
del nostro mondo sensoriale per cui non
solo amici oriento non solo ho
informazioni ma magari quando faccio
shopping avrò anche l'idea a livello
tattile di quello che è il vestito che
voglio comprare
altra cosa importante la parte socia la
partitra stringiamo comunità che anche
qua è molto più profondo che solo il
social network proprio il fare software
in maniera open in maniera community
bass
la parte cloud l'altra grande forza
importante
cos'è claudo anche qua ripeto non vorrei
banalizzarlo ma alla fine come oggi in
modo tradizionale nel system of record
il computing beh se ho bisogno di
qualcosa ho bisogno di un computer ci
deve installare il software per magari
ci deve installare l'applicazione
premolari ci deve installare dei
prerequisiti ea quel punto il servizio
che mi interessa cloud computing è
completamente trasformare questa diciamo
questa catena e usare il servizio di
computing come una utility io oggi vado
a casa mi serve la luce e accende
l'interruttore o la luce quando non mi
servi più lo spento e non mi interessa
nemmeno so cosa c'è dietro questo è
diciamo cloud e volere avere questo
concetto di utility di servizio
all'interno del computer e infine big
data ne parlava il relatore precedente
ripetono ciò che è sorprendente non è
tanto che 90 per cento dei dati è stato
costruito esiste sul pianeta è stato
prodotto negli usa
18 mesi ma la cosa importante è
gli strumenti di analisi degli strumenti
di comprensione di questa mole dati per
poter prevedere ciò che arriverà per
poter prevedere il futuro quali faccio
un esempio così volante
1998 il primo computer che batte il
campione mondiale di scacchi kasparov
sembrava di essere arrivati alla retta
all'himalaya in realtà era ormai è
preistoria per i quali era semplicemente
forza bruta forza di di chip di compiuti
2012 un altro computer watson
vince contro il più forte il campione
statunitense di jeopardy il nostro
rischiatutto quiz rimasto un po
questa estremamente importante perché
non è più forza bruta ma è capacità di
fare deduzione di far asserzioni
capacità di sapere quando si sbaglia e
ripeto vi lascio con me così spunto
provate a pensare watson che vince
contro il campione nazionale
statunitense lee di rischiatutto o di
quiz applicato non a rischiatutto ma per
esempio in ambito medico e già vi potete
rendere poi di quelle che possono essere
le evoluzioni e le disruption innovation
in questo in questo senso
ma per darvi un po più uno spaccato su
come queste questa faglia st ripeti
influenzando la vita di noi tutti e
anche per cercare di rendere un po più
personale volevo parlargli di quattro
esempi che fanno parte della mia vita
quotidiana e che fanno parte del modo in
cui oggi il software sta
evolvendosi ha già dava la mente nessun
sito sono sicuramente ne avete già sito
parlare transparent fattori di scala e
il fattore di composizione alla lega
vediamo che cosa sono
apriamo di come si fa al software quindi
lei in modo tradizionale
alla fine un po simile a una catena di
montaggio automobilisti da secoli a de
finis kirchner chiamaremo dai clienti
dal marketing disegno il mio soft
l'architettura lo implementano testo e
poi lo metto sul mercato
più o meno sembra anche una cosa logica
e ragionevole qual è il problema sono
due problemi uno che proprio a causa di
queste forze social cloud e e mobility
il più delle volte quando arrivi in
fondo è questa diciamo tipicamente un
processo che dura dai 9 ai 18 mesi
quindi intorno all'anno due anni quando
arrivi in fondo molto probabilmente
irregolarmente sono cambiati
e quindi mi trovo con un investimento un
prodotto che non
riflette più ciò che il mercato mi
chiede
secondo problema è che in questo in
questo processo waterfall a cascata
d'acqua
se io non capisco bene un record
dall'inizio perché magari non l'ho
interpretato bene così via
quando me ne accorgo è troppo tardi
quindi il modo oggi di fare software è
proprio quello invece di
lavorare in simbiosi col cliente col
mercato con gli stakeholder in una
interazione continua quindi
sostanzialmente banalizzando un po
invece di aspettare nove mesi o un anno
due anni per tirare fuori un prodotto io
lo faccio a cicli a sprint alterazioni
di due settimane è già quella è una cosa
un manufatto un semilavorato lanciato
pone di vista se auto consistente questo
cosa qual è il vantaggio il vantaggio è
che riesco a cambiare la traiettoria
cammin facendo
e quindi quando arrivi in fondo la
percentuale di successo e quindi il
ritorno di investimento è sicuramente un
ordine di grandezza superiore
altra cosa importante il trans pare
davvero quindi come lavoriamo nei
laboratori in maniera uno s'immagina un
laboratorio tutto chiuso a doppia
mandata
sette livelli di password e così via
in realtà non è così cioè sicuramente ci
sono
dagli aspetti di intellectual property
che sono protetti e sicuramente ci sono
dei livelli di sicurezza ma come oggi
faccio il software lo faccio in maniera
trasparente tramite un meccanismo di
community quindi fondamentalmente mette
in vetrina la mia catena di valore la
mia la mia catena di montaggio e chiedo
alla comunità di intervenire a darmi
feedback a darmi critiche magari anche a
intervenire facendo delle cose nuove
sicuramente ci sono dei rischi che
magari il competitor mi vede quindi può
copiare ma questi sono ampiamente
compensati dal valore che la comunità mi
dà in questo sviluppo software
secondo aspetto gli standard
quindi e la e la e la parte open e anche
questo non è un qualcosa che facciamo
perché ci piace essere moderni quindi
oggi sono per è un modo di sopravvivere
io oggi posso faccio cloud software
davano beh posso creare il miglior
prodotto di cloud computing
ma se parla solo la mia lingua
sarà comunque un qualcosa che non
incontra il favore del mercato
sarebbe come che ne so che la provincia
di bologna fa il sistema ferroviario più
efficiente più bello del mondo ma guarda
caso c'è uno scartamento dei dei binari
che non è compatibile col resto
dell'italia con l'est dell'europa
non penso che i clienti sarebbero
estremamente contenti quindi questo è un
modo è il modo nuovo di fare soste a
livello trasparente sulla comunità che
ripeto non è
diciamo democratico secondo la cattiva
accezione del termine un modo
estremamente elitario estremamente
meritocratico perché la comunità premia
soprattutto il merito
terzo aspetto la parte di
scala fattori di scale anche qua
non può più essere che chi fa software
lo fa nel suo nella sua isoletta nella
sua in maniera completamente diciamo
asincrona aspetta come funziona il mondo
questo non vuol dire che devi essere una
multinazionale
bisogna avere dei degli investi vuol
dire che per fare il software devi
essere connesso a rete quindi questo è
per esempio la fotografia dei laboratori
di quello la responsabilità e il punto
qua non è o quanti sono o sono mille
persone il punto è
il cambiamento anche da un punto di
vista organizzativo
culturale per mettere d'accordo
tutte queste persone che convergono un
progetto software e quindi che
partitamente parte che ne so dall'italia
per poi essere visto in cina per poi
essere magari finito in in germania
quindi il concetto davvero di community
e il concerto anche ancora una volta di
merito e di innovation che sta alla base
oggi dello dello sviluppo software
infine nel cerco di andare veloce
l'ultima
l'ultimo esempio che volevo farvi finora
abbiamo parlato un po della
quelli che un po la governance
del software no come come il software
viene organizzata vediamo un po come
cosa vuol dire farlo
come il come lo costruisco beh nel
maniera tradizionale che poi è ancora
tutt'ora in parte attuale
io devo banalmente prendere un computer
poi devo decidere qual è il sistema
operativo
qua ci sono pre le guerre di religione
non son windows non sono lì non sono
android sono nostro no ios ma comunque
poi ci deve mettere su un compilatore
oppure vogliamo essere un pochettino più
moderne un ambiente di sviluppo
integrato
e poi magari iniziò a costruire la mia
applicazione
a dalla meditazione l'ho fatta
le faccio un pacchetto e magari lo
comincia a far vedere per capire se
incontra il favore o dei miei clienti o
del mercato a seconda di che tipo di
scala su quel tipo di scala sto
lavorando questo è il modo tradizionale
il modo in cui oggi sempre di più e
ancora una volta si è ricordati 4
meteoriti social cloud big data e
mobility il modo in cui il in cui oggi
costruisco al software in maniera
completamente diversa il mio sistema
operativo se vogliamo è la rete io mi
affaccio sulla rete e trovo un
proliferare di platforms service quindi
di piattaforme che mi permettono di
iniziare a costruire software come ma
semplicemente andando a prendere dei
blocchetti anche quando lo banalizzo ma
per rendere l'idea che sono i componenti
di quello che sarà la mia applicazione e
ricomincia a mettere insieme come
veramente come in un lego
e man mano e se vi ricordate il primo
aspetto del ha già il dall'oman comincia
a fare questa piccola costruzione che
poi diventano man mano sempre più
complessa e anche qua non è che mi
faccio il mio dischetto al flop e
cominciò a coinvolgere la comunità e la
comunità mi dà aiuto sia perché magari
mi dice ma noi invece di usare il
blocchetto giallo guarda c'è un
blocchetto blu che fa molto di più al
caso tuo oppure inizia a diciamo
estendere alti altri blocchetti quindi
il punto fondamentale cos'è qua che
verrà viene sempre più o meno viene
sempre più a mancare rella tutta quella
serie di diciamo di ingredienti un
pochettino noiosi no al sistema
operativo il compilatore ma cambia la
versione di compilatore è sempre di più
ci sarà
opportunità per gli innovatori per fare
una disruption espone nation innovation
quindi questo è davvero un qualcosa che
permetterà ancora di più passare
velocemente dall'idea alla realizzazione
ho finito il tempo quindi voglio stare
nei limiti spero che questo gli avviato
qualche spunto e poi comunque ripeto
siamo socio quindi se c'è questa ben up
nome si chiama
mezzo boss posate perfetta verso poi lo
dice lui giusto e quindi siamo connessi
sevieri ha voglia di così di scambiare
informazioni o avere maggiori
informazioni sono ovviamente più che
contento di iniziare
una collaborazione one o one
sempre nell'ottica social grazie